it's iPhone day the most anticipated
tech gadget possibly ever it's Apple and
AT&T stores tonight at 6:00 p.m. this
Thursday will mark 10 years since Apple
released the first iPhone it's got
everything you need bull wrapped up in
one the device changed the way we use
the internet shop learn take pictures
and communicate with each other hello
hello hello
in short with more than a billion
iPhones sold it's become part of our
culture what are you doing well I just
found out about these things called apps
so that's kind of all I do now Apple
co-founder Steve Jobs first showed off
the iPhone nearly six months before it's
released what we're gonna do is get rid
of all these buttons and just make a
giant screen a giant screen at the time
it entered a crowded smartphone market
and Apple's competitors were skeptical
$500 fully subsidized with a plan I said
that is the most expensive phone in the
world and it doesn't appeal to business
customers because it doesn't have a
keyboard not everybody was sure that a
touchscreen on an iPhone could be a
business tool and it took some time but
that was overcome tremendously obviously
to the point where every device has a
touchscreen
the iPhones popularity led to the iPad
and later the Apple watch all of which
fueled Apple's explosive growth to
become the most valuable company in the
world
investors reap the benefits as Apple
shares trading at 17 dollars and 43
cents the day the first iPhone was sold
are now worth nearly 10 times that the
iPhone has generated some controversy
Apple has been criticized for working
conditions in Chinese plants where the
phones are assembled and following the
2015 terror attack in San Bernardino
California our Apple CEO Tim Cook and
then FBI director James Comey had a
public showdown over Apple's refusal to
unlock the gunman's iPhone this is
iPhone 7 ten years on the iPhone is in
its seventh generation with an 8 soon to
come today's devices can recognize your
voice your fingerprints and even your
heartbeat but despite being on the
cutting edge of technology a decade from
now the iPhone may be a thing of the
past 10 years is a very long time in
tech so I I think in in some ways you'll
always have something on you I do feel
like the idea of always looking at a
screen in your pocket might change I
fought that iPhone in the beginning I
wanted my keyboard and now I can't
believe I can't live without it it's
next to me right no I still happen to
have a blackberry and everybody laughs
at me if I had known that I would've
laughs yeah that's the last time I have
my iPhone too we'll see what happens in
10 years